how do we want the audience to leave
whether we want to give them maybe we
can't achieve all of our goals with each
project we may start out thinking we
want to entertain them we want to
distract them we want to hopefully
Gustavo said in a sense educate them
have them in a state of elation or
finding of new information new
understanding as they're entertained
it's a wonderful opportunity in film
fabulous it will broaden to billions of
people around the world and I think
perhaps all of these things can be
achieved to some degree in each project
that we do as you do with each interview
you may not get all of it but you send
them away with part of what your hopes
have for that have been you edify them
if you can
or they will edify you in some way
that's right and you will gain as much
as they will and the audience in the
process will be the beneficiaries the
second question about a personal thing
in life that may affect what my work has
been and it's a very it's a great
question and I really don't know if this
is the appropriate forum but I will give
you a straight answer when I was about
40 years old I lost somebody very very
very close to me unexpectedly and before
that point in my life I didn't know what
I was doing but after that point in my
writing in my approach to music and
everything I was doing I felt certain it
was clear about what it is I was trying
to do and how I could do it with
whatever small gift I may have been
given it was a huge emotional turning
point in my life let's leave it there
but but one that resonates with me still
and taught me about who I was and what I
was doing and what it meant and this is
a deeply emotional saying
and in the way that was the greatest
gift ever given to me if I can put it
that way by anyone and so that's the
best answer I can give you am certainly
a pivotal moment in my thinking and my
living in my life and approaching the
blank page absolutely I immediately knew
that where to go with this emotionally